can't have sex with you while you're
texting yes I can get that back does
your dad know that you lost your job
I got a 24 on my final but find out
you're screwing off can say goodbye to
the house car all of it all I have to do
is just pass my business classes I
professor made me an offer
LoJack run it for a week show a profit
do that you pass kind of business car
wash
Shiratori - then you get some business
oh sure yeah why don't we just open up a
bikini car wash this is gonna be awesome
poor history blah blah blah what are
your best assets
yeah the cash now it's your job to pay
it back that don't work out things that
are attached to your body
hey stop break
so you have girls in bikinis washing
cars
it's a bikini car wash she can not have
girls in bikinis well Jack did just
start a business really all right ladies
remember sexy not [__] with a little
nudity I told the girls it was okay to
sex it up out there everything is on the
line here I'm screwed pretty much I'm
doing it because of my girl your girls
oh those girls there's a line that you
don't want to cross what the carwash we
make sure nothing bad happens their car
washed and looking at and definitely
could explode
your dad is here what the hell is going
on this is the business
it's gonna kick ass most of the jobs
I've had we're under the table as in no
vex off the Pokes man I know what under
the table means
you